[Musique]
jusqu'à rendez-vous à la ferme pour
Catherine delacoutte chef du Lancelot
elle rend visite à son producteur de
volaille à Donnery avant d'aller à bout
pour les pleurotes
à essence splendide c'est extraordinaire
quand on les a à la maison pour les
cuisiner c'est vrai un vrai plaisir
avec les confinements les producteurs
locaux sont allés chercher des débouchés
directement chez les restaurateurs
on cherche vraiment à développer cette
nouvelle cuisine travailler au mieux au
plus proche de chez nous et d'avoir
vraiment les produits qui sont
qui sont de première qualité et sans
transport mais on est beaucoup de mal à
trouver tous ces producteurs avec le
covid tout le monde a cherché à se
vendre autrement tout le monde a cherché
à faire du chiffre parce que ben c'était
compliqué et puis comme
les personnes restées chez eux ils sont
partis chercher autour de chez eux à
manger
donc tous ces faits naturellement
la chef a ouvert le Lancelot en 1994 à
Chilleurs-aux-Bois après un passage par
deux établissements étoilés à Orléans
pour Catherine delacoutte la cuisine
c'est une affaire de famille
j'ai été percée dedans avec ma mère qui
travaillait pour nous mais qui travaille
beaucoup beaucoup en cuisine et
j'adorais j'étais passionné parce
qu'elle faisait surtout les saveurs
qu'elle donnait à chaque produit avec
des bons produits et
l'envie d'aller dans ce métier
c'est fait naturellement
ça a été une découverte mais j'ai suivi
un instinct si la mise en valeur du
produit est son point fort notre chef
fait ses gammes avec le sucre et salé
les herbes et les aromates en 28 ans de
cuisine son style a forcément évolué
les gens se nourrissent plus de la même
manière surtout et on mange rapidement
avant prenez le temps de manger on était
à table c'était un plaisir maintenant on
a moitié en temps pour prendre notre pas
donc on doit faire des choses plus
simples
mais très bonne surtout de la découverte
ils aiment les petites découvertes dans
la sienne aujourd'hui l'heure est à la
transmission pour Catherine qui
accueille Thomas Jeanne un nouveau chef
au fourneau si elle prend un peu de
distance avec la cuisine la chef ne
raccroche pas pour autant son tablier
[Musique]
Thomas quand il est pas là je le
remplace je suis je reste dedans je j'ai
la vision sur tout
sauf que je suis obligé de déléguer vu
tout ce que l'on a à faire actuellement
pour avancer je ne peux pas être à tous
les postes donc je suis obligé de
déléguer et de me faire rigoler avec
quelqu'un
transmettre l'établissement de toute une
vie c'est incapable à passer dans une
carrière de chef après des années en
cuisine Catherine de la Coupe souhaite
relancer sa petite entreprise autrement
en restant toujours bien ancré dans son
époque